.בוקר טוב, דוד
...אם אתה-
.אבל תגמור לשתות קודם
,אני אשתה תוך כדי
.אני לא מפריע
אנחנו... אני רוצה
,לשאול אותך שאלה
העלייה שלך היא כתוצאה
,ממניעים ציוניים
...מרדיפה, מ
,בוא נגיד ככה-
אני גדלתי בבית יהודי דתי
.בירושלים
וכשאבא שלי נלקח למחנה ריכוז
.אני נהייתי ציפור דרור
.והצטרפתי לשומר הצעיר
.ומשם הגעתי לעליית הנוער
אבא שלי ניצול
...משום שהייתה לו ויזה ל
...הוא קיבל ויזה
.האנגלים הצילו אותו
...הוא היה במחנה
,תשעה חודשים במחנה ריכוז
האנגלים נתנו לו
אישור כניסה רק לו
...לא לאשתו, לא לילד שלו זה
אפרופו מלחמת העולם
.היה אז
?אז מתי אתה מגיע לכאן
?באיזה תאריך
,שלושה חודשים אחרי פרוץ המלחמה
.'בנובמבר 39
...נובמבר 39'. -זה פשוט מאוד, זה
.אגב, המצלמה רצה? -כן כן
זה 39' משום שצריך לזכור
שהיטלר התחיל
.את המלחמה ב-1 בספטמבר
.'איטליה הצטרפה רק במאי 40
'עד מאי 40
.הלכו אוניות מטרייסט לחיפה
,הגלילה המפורסמת
.אוניית העלייה. -כן
,האונייה שהביאה הרבה
.הכי הרבה עולים
...כל עליות נוער זה
,גלילה הלכה פעמיים
,כל שבוע הלוך ושוב
.חיפה-טרייסט
וכמעט כל עליית הנוער
,באה על גלילה
.'וזה עד 40
עליית הנוער הצליחה להוציא
,את הילדים מגרמניה ומאוסטריה
,להביא אותם לטרייסט
.ומטרייסט הייתה עלייה פשוטה
,והגעתי לקיבוץ, קיבוץ השומר הצעיר
.בית זרע
וכל שנות מלחמת העולם השנייה
...בעצם עוברות עליך ב
.בקיבוץ עדיין. אה, לא, לא, לא
,כשהגעתי לגיל 18
.'שאז אני... זה 42
,כן? -שנת 1942
.מתגייס כמו כל יהודי טוב
.כן. -מתגייס לצבא הבריטי
,נשארו ארבע שנים
.קצת למעלה מ-4 שנים בצבא הבריטי
,משרת באפריקה, צפון אפריקה
,מלטה, איטליה
...כל הדרך למעלה עד ל
.גמרנו בבריסל בבלגיה
מתי בפעם הראשונה
בתוך המסעות האלה
?פגשת ניצול שואה
?פגשת יהודי שבא משם
כשהבריגדה הייתה מוצבת
,בגבול איטליה אוסטריה
ואז הפכה הבריגדה ממלחמה בנאצים
.למלחמה בבריטים
.כלומר, להבריח יהודים
אני הייתי בין אלה שנסעו במשאיות
,ונהגתי עם אוטו
משאית מלאה פליטים
,מלנדסברג בגרמניה
,היו שם הרבה אנשים לא מרוצים
?מה שקראו לזה, כן
.שיצאו ממחנות ריכוז
והעברנו אותם לנמלים
.בנאפולי, בחיפה, בגנואה
,וכאדם שבא מאירופה וחי כאן
מתי פעם ראשונה
אתם הבנתם בארץ
,או שלא, או בזמן הבריגדה
?מה מתחולל באמת
.קשה לי להגיד את זה
.אולי משום שהייתי צעיר מדי
אני שברתי על זה הרבה
.את הראש
אני חושב שהבנו את זה
.רק לקראת סוף המלחמה
.לקראת סוף המלחמה. -כן
ובראייה היסטורית, מה הייתה
...הסיבה אתה חושב שלא
בראייה היסטורית
,שאתה מסתכל היום לאחור
?מה הייתה הסיבה
...הייתה סיבה
לבריטים ודאי לא היה אינטרס
.שהעם היהודי ידע מה קורה
.לא להתסיס. -בוודאי
,אני חושב שאת ממדי האסון
.אולי מעטים בפסגה ידעו
...אני חושב שמעולם לא היה
.כלומר, מי שצריך היה לדעת, ידע
.אני מתאר שרוזוולט ידע
גם כן, לא בטוח שהוא ידע
.את כל הממדים
מכיוון שאם אני חושב
על התדהמה שבה אייזנהאואר
,ראה את מחנה הריכוז הראשון
אז כנראה
,גם שכבות גבוהות מאוד בעולם
...לא היה ברור להם מה
השוק שאייזנהאואר קיבל
כשהוא נכנס לדכאו
מראה שאפילו
ברמות גבוהות מאוד בעולם
...ממדי האסון לא יכלו
,יכול להיות שהיו כאלה
.קשה היום להאשים אותם, אני יודע
,אתה מנהל מלחמה
.מה צ'רצ'יל ידע, מה הוא לא ידע
.הייתה לו מלחמה קשה מאוד לנהל
עכשיו, בחלק הזה של הבריחה
...אתה נאלץ
...אתה... הבריטים
אתה משתחרר מהצבא שם
...או שאתה משתחרר ונשאר
?חוזר לארץ להשתחרר
,מחזירים אותנו לארץ להשתחרר
.אבל קודם הייתי בחופשה פעם בארץ
.ב-45' נראה לי
.כן, 45' הייתי בחופשה בארץ
.לפני סוף המלחמה-
,ואחר כך חזרתי
.וב-46' השתחררתי
.'סוף 46
.אז חזרת לפה להשתחרר-
,חזרתי לפה להשתחרר
,כבר לא חזרתי לקיבוץ
.כבר נשארתי בירושלים
ואז גם מתחיל הרומן שלך
.עם צילום? -לא
הרומן שלי עם צילום
...מתחיל בבריגדה. אני
...מה היה הרגע הזה שבו נכנסת
זה סיפורים... זה או שאני אספר אותו
,במצגות, יש לי מצגת
.אני מספר אותו
...הרגע ש
,חגיגות שנה לשחרור פריז
.קיבלנו חופש
,גם עם כרטיס לאופרה
.היה לי
,הגענו לפריז, כמה חברים ואני
.עוד חבר
,היו לנו כרטיסים לאופרה
.הגענו לאופרה
,דקות יותר מדי מאוחר 2
.הדלתות סגורות
."אחרי המערכה הראשונה תבואו"
?מה עושים שני חיילים
...אוכלים מעבר לפינה ב
.מי שמכיר את פריז
,שם היה בר
,בבר היו קלודט וג'נט
,לאופרה כבר לא הלכנו
אבל עם קלודט התפתחה
.אהבה רצינית
...וכשקיבלתי אחר כך ב
אני לא יודע אם בספטמבר
,'או אוקטובר 45
,קיבלתי חופשת מולדת
.היא נתנה לי מצלמה קטנה
,ארגוס קטנה, מאוד זולה
.אמריקאית
ואיתה נסעתי ארצה
.והתחלתי לצלם בקיבוץ עם המצלמה
.מצא חן בעיניי מה שזה עושה
אני אמרתי, זה מה שאני רוצה
.לעשות בחיים
,קלודט היא מפנה בחיים שלי
.אין ספק
,כן. ועכשיו, כשאתה חוזר לארץ
אז המצלמה מלווה אותך
בעצם עכשיו בתקופה הזאת
.של המאבק
...אתה ב-1946 אתה בן
.22-
כבר התחתנתי- .22
,גם בחוץ לארץ
כיוון שהתחתנתי
.עם ניצולת שואה. -כן
חתונה פיקטיבית
.בשביל להעלות אותה ארצה
,אבל שכחנו להתגרש
.נשארנו 54 שנה
אז אני כבר בחזרה
,'עם אישה וב-47
.כבר נולדה הבת הראשונה שלי
?איפה גרתם, בירושלים
.בירושלים-
סביבה שהיא היום
.כמעט מאה שערים
,ומבחינת פרנסה
?מה אתה עושה בשנים האלה
קודם כול, כשהשתחררתי
מהצבא הבריטי
נתנו לי ג'וב במשרד החקלאות הבריטי
שזה מה שהיום
המלון המפואר ביותר
,במה שהיה פעם
...מלון פאלאס והיום זה
?איך זה נקרא
.הכי מפואר בירושלים
.איך? -אמריקן קולוני? -לא
?לא. -לא
.מוכר, שם מוכר
.אני עם שמות... -או.קיי
.בעיה של גיל, שוכח שמות-
,אבל לא חשוב
.עבדתי במחלקה הווטרינרית
.הייתי עוזר מחסני וטרינריה
וכעבור כמה חודשים
.אמרתי, אני רוצה לצלם
עזבתי את הג'וב
,שהכניס לי אז 27 לירות
.זה היה הרבה כסף
.ואמרתי, לא, אני רוצה לצלם
במקום 27 לירות, אולי הרווחתי
.לפעמים 8, 9, 10 לירות ליום
.לחודש
.אבל אשתי עמדה לצדי
.הפכנו את החדר היחיד שגרנו בו
,בערב הייתי אומר לה
עכשיו את צריכה ללכת לישון
,כיוון שאני עושה חושך
.צריך לפתח תמונות
...והייתי כל שבוע
,קניתי לי אופנוע
הייתי יורד לתל אביב
,"ל"דבר השבוע
,"ל"עולם הזה
,כל העיתונים
...מוכר תמונות ו
.עד שהעולם הזה גילה אותי
,'אורי אבנרי גילה אותי ב-51
.לקח אותי כצלם
,ואז הייתי גם כן שוב
.הלוך ושוב
אז בוא נדבר על התקופה
,שכבר מתחיל המצור בירושלים
?כ"ט... איפה היית בכ"ט בנובמבר
.כ"ט בנובמבר הייתי בירושלים
וצילמתי את הצילום הראשון
שלמעשה הפך להיות
.לצילום עיתונאות
...יצאנו בלילה ואני בבוקר
,כולם יצאו בלילה, ב-12 בלילה
אחרי שנודע על ההחלטה
,של האו"ם
אני לא חושב
.שמישהו נשאר בבית
,יצאנו לכל הרחובות
.ריקודים ברחובות
אני זוכר שאשתי ניגשה לקיוסק
.לבקש קופסת סיגריות, אמפייר
,היא עישנה אמפייר
.אני זוכר את זה
...והאיש נותן לה
.'הקיוסק היה ברחוב קינג ג'ורג
:האיש נותן לה קופסה ואומר
.הלילה אני לא לוקח כסף
.ונשארנו כל הלילה בחוץ
בבוקר פתאום אני רואה
,בריטית של המשטרה הבריטית
נוסעת, וחבר'ה צעירים
.קופצים עליה
.עלו עם דגל וזה... וצילמתי
.את הצילום הזה
:ואחד למעלה על... בחור צעיר
."מדינה עברית, עלייה חופשית"
,חמישים שנה אחר כך
...הטלוויזיה הישראלית שחררה
.שחררנו את הצילום
,חלק מהם כבר לא היו בחיים
.אבל את מי שמצאנו, מצאנו
וזה שצעק הכי הרבה
,"מדינה עברית, מדינה חופשית"
אותו היינו צריכים להביא
.מקליפורניה בשביל הצילום
?אז הצילום הזה הוא הראשון שמה
?שמתפרסם
לא, הראשון שאני קורא לו-
.בעל ערך עיתונאי
.צילמתי הרבה לפני זה
.צילמתי עוד בגרמניה אפילו
,צילמתי אנשים עולים על רכבות
.איך שנסעו אז
...בין הקרונות היו יושבים על
...התחלתי לצלם אבל
מכרתי, היה עיתון שנקרא
,הד המזרח" בירושלים"
.מכרתי להם תמונות
.מה שראיתי ברחוב
,או איזה ילדים
.או למשל עוד לפני זה צילמתי במצור
.גאולה, מאה שנים היו במצור
אז אני מצלם אנשים זורקים לחם
.מחוץ למצור, לתוך המצור
.כל מיני דברים כאלה
.וחיילים בריטים שבין גדרות התיל
אבל הצילום הראשון
,שהיה לו בעיניי היום
,שאני רואה אותו
,שיש לו איזו משמעות היסטורית
היה הצילום
.של כ"ט בנובמבר. -כן
,וביחס שלך לתקופה
,כשאתה מסתכל על האירועים
,אתה רואה את ירושלים במצור
.אתה רואה את הבריטים
אגב, ב-1947, אתה האמנת
?שתקום מדינה, שזה יצליח
כבר שלחו אותי ,'47
,לקורס בהר הצופים
.קורס הגנה ראשון
,כן, אני חושב שהאמנתי
.אני חושב שהאמנתי
.הייתי ציוני שרוף. -כן
.שרוף, שרוף, שרוף
ומה היה היחס שלך
?לגבי המחתרות
?לגבי האצ"ל והלח"י
,אני יודע דבר אחד
,שביום מסוים של מלחמת השחרור
,הייתי ברחוב יפו
.על יד בנק לאומי
,בית אחד
היינו צריכים להביא מרגמות
או יותר נכון פצירה
בשביל להוריד מהפצצות
קצת מהזנב כי הן לא התאימו
.לתוך תוצרת הבית
,והייתי רץ
,ואני יודע שבית שהיה שם
שאותו כבשו האצ"ל מהערבים
ושמר על הדרך
בין מה שאחר כך נהייתה
העירייה של ירושלים
לבין בנק לאומי, לאן שהייתי צריך
,להביא פצירה
הבית הזה היה צריך להיות
,בידיים של אצ"ל
,ואני משם קיבלתי אש עצומה
.ששניים נהרגו על ידי
...כלומר, האצ"ל
מאז לא אהבתי את האצ"ל
משום שהם עזבו את הבית הזה
ואנחנו היינו בטוחים
.שהוא מגן על הצד שלנו
.לא הגן עלינו, הם עזבו
...מבחינה פוליטית, נשארתי
הלא גדלתי בשומר הצעיר
,את השנים החשובות
.נשארתי באותו צד
.עכשיו, דיברת על המצור
?אתה יוצא מירושלים בתקופה הזאת
כל מלחמת העצמאות
?היית בירושלים
.הייתי מפקד מחלקה, עדיין בלי מדים
,זאת אומרת בז'קט
יש לי צילומים שלי
בימין משה שאני יושב בעמדה
עם ז'קט ספורט
...ועם
,ואחר כך הייתי
,כשנהייתי מפקד מחלקה
שלחו אותי לעין כרם
,על הגבעות שם
.מיס קרי זה נקרא
.ושירתי בזה
,וכן, הייתי בבניין טאנוס
.החזקתי את בניין טאנוס
.אז בוא נדבר על הקרב הזה
בניין טאנוס הוא הבניין
,שעמד מול שער יפו
.כבר לא קיים
.היום זה הקיר... משהו
ושם עמד בניין טאנוס
שחטף אש מהמגדל
.של שער יפו, ששם ישב לגיון
הם ישבו עם תותח שם ופה ושם
.הכניסו פגז
,ואני הייתי כמפקד מחלקה
.היה לי סדר
,ויום אחד אני זוכר
,אני ירדתי בשביל לראות למטה
.הייתה לנו עמדת מאג
ירדתי לראות את הבחור הזה
.אם הוא בסדר עם המאג שם
.וכשחזרתי לחדר החדר לא היה
,אבל זה היה
.זה נכנס בחדר בזמן שלא הייתי
.קצת מזל, צריך מזל בחיים
...אז זה ה
,שמע, עברתי את כל המלחמות
.ברוך השם, בלי שריטה
הפציעה הראשונה במלחמה
...הייתה לי דווקא בקפריסין ולא
?איך הגעת לקפריסין
...עבדתי בשביל... אני החל
,"עבדתי בשביל "העולם הזה
,אחר כך נהייתי פרילנס
ומ-56' או אפילו לפני זה
.התחילו להעסיק אותי אמריקאים
?באיזו שנה היית בקפריסין
.רגע, לא... -בשתי המלחמות
.'ו-74 ,'64
."בשביל "לייף
,"הראשונה בשביל "לייף
."השנייה בשביל "טיים
,מעט מאוד אנשים, אתה יודע
היום יודעים שהייתה
.מלחמה בקפריסין... -שתי מלחמות
.שתי מלחמות, כן
.ועד היום יש שטח כבוש-
כן, אחר כך עוד הייתי המון פעמים
.לצלם את השטח
הלוואי שהיו לנו יחסים כאלה
,עם הערבים
.כמו שיש להם
,למרות ששונאים אחד את השני
...אבל היחסים
.הם באו על השכר
,כן. -אז או.קיי
,עכשיו, בתקופה הזאת
.אני חוזר לתקופת המצור בירושלים
עם השיירות יצא לך לראות
.או משהו כזה? -לא, לא, לא
צילמתי פעם אחת שיירה
,שהגיעה ברוממה
,יצא לי לעשות צילומים
...אבל מלבד זה לא היה לי שום
.אני הייתי חלק מהחטיבה הירושלמית
שהיא לא הייתה בדיוק
.יחידה מאוד מאוד קרבית
,ונשארה גם תחת
...אחר כך, אחרי
...כלומר, כשהרצוג היה מפקד
,חיים הרצוג היה מפקד החטיבה
.אז כבר היה שונה
...כבר הייתי
,אומנם הייתי כביכול קצין
,אבל לא עברתי אף פעם
.לא שלחו אותי לקורס קצינים
נשארתי טוראי
.למרות שהייתי מפקד מחלקה
...אני זוכר, הרצוג
.פרצה מלחמת קדש
אני שמעתי שבחיפה
.תפסו אונייה מצרית
,דיסטרוייר. אז נורא רציתי לנסוע
אז הרצוג אמר לי: אבל יכול להיות
.שאני צריך אותך פה
.אתה יודע מה, תיסע
,אבל אם קורה משהו בראשון
.אתה מיד חוזר לפה
אני וחיים הרצוג
,בכלל היינו ביחסים טובים
.הוא אמר לי: אל תבוא במדים
.תבוא באזרחי, תוכל לשבת איתנו
ואת יום הכרזת המדינה
?כשבתל אביב מכריזים, איפה היית
...אז שכבתי
,זה, אז שכבתי ליד
,מה שסיפרתי לך
שירו עלינו מהבניין
.שחשבתי שאצ"ל מחזיק אותו
תראה, אני הייתי אז מוצב
.במה שאחר כך נהיה עיריית ירושלים
,מי שמכיר את ירושלים
.עיריית ירושלים הישנה
...והיה לנו
.הייתה לנו מרגמה תוצרת בית
אבל התגלה שהזנבות
,של הפצצות שהיו לנו
.לא התאימו, צריך לפצר קצת
.שלחו אותי להביא פצירה
.וזה היה באותו יום, באותו יום
.זה היה ביום הכרזת המדינה
.חזרתי ושכבתי שם בחוץ בגינה
,שני הרוגים על ידי
.אני מצאתי איזה קיר קטן
ועל יד זה יש עץ שעד היום
,אני הולך לראות את העץ
כיוון שרואים עדיין את המקומות
.איפה שהכדורים נכנסו בעץ
...עד שבא השריון שלנו והכניס כמה
התחיל לפתוח בירי על הבניין
,שהערבים ישבו בו
."וצעק לי "תקפוץ
'ואז קפצתי את העשרה מ
.לכניסה של בנק ברקליס, זה היה אז
,ועם הפצירה שלי
.הגעתי עם הפצירה, ברוך השם
.יכולנו לפצור את הפצצות
.אז זה היה ביום הכרזת המדינה
,זה היה ממש ביום הכרזת המדינה
.ה-14, עד כמה שאני זוכר
.כן
?טוב, וצילומים חזקים של הבריטים
,תמונות חזקות שקשורות לבריטים
?אתה זוכר משהו
.לא. לא הרבה, לא הרבה
,צילמתי אותם במאה שערים
,יש שם מוצב צבאי
.אלה הצילומים הראשונים
?בווינגרדים-
?יצא לך לצלם את הבוויגרד
...את ה
?בווינגרד, יצא, ודאי, יצא. -כן
.כן, זה יצא לי
אבל גם יצא לי לצלם
,ביום הכרזת המדינה
...מיד אחרי זה ב
,לא, יום אחרי כ"ט בנובמבר
,ב-1 בדצמבר
התחילו ההפגנות הגדולות
.בדרום ירושלים
,במה שנקרא המרכז המסחרי
.שם צילמתי
...צילמת בזמן האירועים
.כן, שם יש לי צילומים מהאירועים-
...שהבריטים מנסים
...ההגנה מנסה
הם מנסים לרדת שם
והבריטים חוסמים
.ולא נותנים להם לעבור. -כן
הצילומים האלה נגישים
.לראות אותן היכן שהוא? -פה
.כן? -כן
,"הארכיון שלי ב"ידיעות אחרונות
.אבל יש לי קשר איתם
,אני מכרתי להם את הארכיון
...אבל אני עדיין
,אז תראה, אולי נגמר לי הזמן
אז אם אפשר לשים
אולי רק תמונה או שתיים
.מתקופת מלחמת העולם השנייה
.יש המון, בשמחה
.אתה יכול מהמסך לצלם אותן? -כן
...אז יאללה, תן לי רק
.בוא ננסה את זה
,תן לי להזיז
אני אגש ואני אתחיל לחפש
?צילומים שמתאימים לנושא, טוב
,פה אני כבר יודע
אני חושב שאני יכול
לעשות את זה גם בעזרת
.הדאטה-בייס שלי, נראה מיד
.קודם כול ניכנס לתמונות
."עצמאות"
"לא, "עצמאות
.לא נותן לי שום דבר
.אז רגע
.או, זה כבר נותן לי יותר
.כן
איכשהו אנחנו נחפש את זה
.בצורה קצת אחרת
אני רואה שפה יש לי
יותר מדי דברים
.שקשורים ליום העצמאות
מיליון תמונות שלי
.מיום העצמאות. -כן
."משום שכתבתי "עצמאות
"...ננסה עם "מלחמת ה
.יותר פשוט
.פה זה דברים, תמונות מהמלחמות
,כל מיני מלחמות, נו
?איפה מלחמת העצמאות
...הנה, זה למשל תמונה מאוד
.גם כן, אחרי מלחמת העצמאות
זו ועדת שביתת הנשק
.הישראלית-ערבית. -כן
.הנה, זה על יד שער יפו
.זה ממלחמת השחרור עוד
.בעין כרם
.למשל. לא מספיק מעניין
.זו מלחמת ששת הימים
.במיס קרי למעלה
רגע, אני רוצה תמונות
.שהן יותר אישיות
...צריך לחפש את זה בצורה קצת
?אולי לפני שנים-
.לפי 1948? -אולי לפי שנים
.חכה, נראה. אני רוצה עוד לעבור
,בכל זאת
...פה אני מוצא את מה ש
?'בעצם האישה הזאת זה לא 48
.זה ארבעים... כן
.זה 48' אבל זה אימונים
.'אבל זה כן, זה צולם ב-48
.מהאימונים ל... -כן
.זה באימונים-
אני חושב שאני אחפש את זה
.בצורה אחרת
אני אחפש את זה
,בצורה שאני זוכר
.של צילומים שאני זוכר
,מה דיברנו? קודם כול
...בואו נראה את ה
...אני יודע, הצילום שלי... -של ה
.כ"ט בנובמבר? -כן, כן
.כ"ט בנובמבר, זה קל
.הנה
...זה הצילום הראשון שבן אדם
.זה הבחור שצעק, זה
,"הוא צעק "מדינה עברית
.אחר כך הבאנו אותו מלוס אנג'לס
?אז זה כאן מספיק גדול בשבילך
.כן, אני בזום-אין-
.לא, זה נראה טוב מאוד
,בתקופה הזאת
?עם איזו מצלמה אתה מצלם
.זאת מצולמת עם לייקה
.לייקה 35
.לייקה, כן. 35 מ"מ, כן-
אני צילמתי אז או עם רוליפלקס
.או עם לייקה
.זאת אני זוכר שהיא צילום לייקה
אני רואה את זה
.גם לפי המספר אל
.אל זה נקרא לייקה
.אפשר להעביר? -כן
?אז מה עוד אמרנו
...נחפש את עצמי ב
.בימין משה
.נמצא את זה לפי זה
.או, הנה. -כן
.הנה. עבדך הנאמן, מפקד מחלקה
.מדהים
.אז זה... מישהו צילום אותך
מישהו צילם אותי וכנראה
.אני נתתי את המצלמה לחבר
?עכשיו, מה עוד אנחנו זוכרים
,דיברנו על... -רגע
,ואני יכול לראות עוד את אלה
.שקשורים לעצמאות? כן
.כן, כן, בוודאי-
.זה גם מימין משה. -כן
,זה, אגב
.נהיה פקיד גבוה במשרד האוצר
.להעביר? אני אעביר
.כן, כן-
?אני יכול להעביר הלאה
,יש גם פה
.גם כן מלחמת השחרור
,זה איפה? גם מימין משה
.גם מימין משה. -כן
,זו גם המחלקה שלי
.אחרת לא הייתי יכול לצלם שם
.גם פה, זה אולי מעניין
.איפה שלנו
.זו המחלקה שלי
.זה היה בבית טאנוס
נראה אם הכותרת שלי
."גם אומרת "בית טאנוס
.ימין משה... לא, עמדת ימין משה
.וגם נחפש עוד משהו לפי זה
.לפי מה נוכל לחפש עוד? רגע
?מה עוד יכול להיות קשור לזה
.כן, אולי. זה אולי יהיה מעניין
.הנה, רבין והרצוג
.'ב-55', זה כבר 55
...זה כבר לא כל כך
.רבין הוא כבר רמטכ"ל נדמה לי
.לא, הוא אלוף
.הוא אלוף, הוא אלוף
...הוא נכנס ל '64
?כן. 54' הוא נהיה-
.'לא, רמטכ"ל הוא נהיה ב-64
.זהו, אז פה הוא אלוף, כן-
?כן. מה
.זה הרצוג
גם כן. זה הכול
...כבר יותר ב-55', זה כבר
.פה, פה גם כן רבין עם הרצוג
...כן, זה באותו ה
,אתה שאלת אותי אם אני צילמתי
.אם צילמתי את הבריטים. -כן
אז בוא נראה
.איפה אני אמצא את זה
?אולי מנדט
.מנדט? אולי, אתה צודק
.לא
.כן, כן, כן, יש, יש, יש
.הנה מה ש... -או.קיי
הנה, האנגלים חוסמים
...בין אנשי ההגנה שרוצים
,פה זה איפה שהערבים התפרעו
...למטה פה בסביבת
.איפה שממילה
.אז זה ה-30 בנובמבר-
.זה היה ב-30 בנובמבר
.הנה, כתוב כאן. -מדהים
כן. -ופה אנשי ההגנה
שמנסים לרדת
והבריטים חוסמים את הכביש
.ולא נותנים לעבור
אז זה בעצם עדות מצולמת
ליום שבו התחילה מלחמת העצמאות
.לפי ה... -כן, כן
.כן. -לפני קום המדינה
.הנה, גם פה חוסמים
.חוסמים את הכביש
.לא, אולי מקש שמאלי אתה עושה
.לא, עשיתי בכוונה-
?הנה, אתה רואה
הנה אנשי ההגנה מנסים לרדת
.והבריטים חוסמים
.זה פה
.מחסום של... ב-47'. -כן
הצבא הבריטי
,ליד מאה שערים בירושלים
...מאחורי
כן, זה חשוב להבין
.'איזו אווירה הייתה פה ב-47
.איך נראתה ירושלים
.כן, זה גאולה, זה רחוב גאולה-
.כן. -רגע, או פה
אולי זה אפילו צילום קלאסי
.לתקופה ההיא. -כן
...למרות שאני חושב ש
אני לא יודע
,איפה דעותיך הפוליטיות
שאני אומר הלוואי שהחיילים שלנו
,היו מתייחסים כך
מתנהגים כמו שהחיילים הבריטים
.התנהגו
.בסופו של דבר הם היו פיירים
הנה, מעבירים אוכל
...לאנשים שנמצאים בשטח
.מצב צבאי
.אז מצאנו תמונות שמתאימות
?פה למטה זה גם, לא
.לא, זה פיצוץ רחוב בן יהודה
,אה, זה פברואר
.בטח, זה חשוב מאוד
.פברואר 48'. -כן
.הנה. -וואו
.היית שם, הא? -כן, צילמתי
רצתי לשם, אני זוכר עוד
.את הבוקר שרצתי לשם
שמעתי את הפיצוץ העצום
.בפברואר 22. -כן
,כן, זה כבר ממש סוף המנדט
...את זה בעצם עושים חיילים
?אתה יודע מי זה-
?מי זה
.זה אחד שנקרא מאיר-
,הוא הסבא של גדעון מאיר
.שהוא שגריר ישראל ברומניה
,זה בחור שהיה איתי בבריגדה
.הוא היה צלם
.היחידי שצילם, עם בוקס הוא צילם
...יש שם עוד אחד מה
,אין לי, היה לי על יד זה
,אבל אני חושב שזה אותו דבר
.דומה מאוד. לא, זה אותו דבר
,אני אגיד לך, אנשים שואלים אותי
,מכיוון שזה מצולם ברוליפלקס
?עד כמה שאני זוכר. -כן
,שואלים אותי לפעמים
...למה אין לך רק
,אמרתי, חבר'ה
.סרט עלה שמונה לירות
.תמונות, לחצת 12
.חשבת פעמיים לפני שלחצת
הרוליפלקס זה זה
?שמסתכלים מלמעלה, נכון
?מה? -הנה, זו זאת
.לא, זאת... כן, כזאת, כן
.כן. -הייתה לי כזו
זו הייתה... אשתי בסוף
...צילמה את ה
.אז זה 12 תמונות
היית חושב פעמיים
לפני שלחצת. -כן
?אז זה, ראינו אותו
.זה עוד פעם אותו דבר
.לא, זה לא ראינו
.אבל זו אותה החבורה-
זה... נדמה לי שזה מה שיש לי
.בנושאים המתאימים
."לא, מצאנו את זה תחת "בריטי
...למה זה כותב לי כל הזמן
.או.קיי, זהו
אני חושב שבכל זאת
?מצאנו קצת חומר, נכון
.בהחלט, מעולה. -יופי, אני שמח
.נתת לי תמונה-
אני שמח. -אני מודה לך
.ואני סוגר, זהו
.שמיר
אלה. טוב, אלה כמובן תמונות
.שגם אחרים מופיעים
...בגין
אבל הנה שמיר למשל
.כיושב ראש כשסאדאת מדבר
כן. רגע, אני רוצה
.לראות את זה. כן. וואו
כן, הא? מפקד הלח"י ומפקד האצ"ל
.מארחים את נשיא מצרים. -כן
בוא נראה
.אם יש עוד משהו מעניין
?עם מי הוא פה
.לא. רגע, זה לא יכול להיות
.אה, אני עברתי לתמונה אחרת
.הלמוט קוהל כן, חשבתי שזה הוא
.עם נשיא גרמניה. -כן
.הלמוט קוהל
.אבל רגע, פה זה חזר
,אה, יש לי משהו נחמד של שמיר
.שבטח תאהב את זה
.נו, אוי לא
,לא הייתי צריך לסובב את זה
.סובבתי את זה
,זה... אתה בטח תאהב את זה
.זה מאוד נחמד
.סובב מסך
,הנה. בתוך מטוס
.מדליקים חנוכייה באל על. -מדהים
.אשתו שולמית. -כן
?מה יש עוד משמיר
.רגע, רגע, רגע
אה, פה עם בגין במטוס
.בדרך לקמפ דיוויד
.עם בורק. -כן
.היסטוריה. הדרך לקמפ דיוויד
.עם משה וחצי. -כן
.אני הייתי נשוי לאחיינית שלו
.מה יש לי עוד? שיכול להיות מעניין
.עם בורק
.עם... -בוש. -בוש. -כן
.בוושינגטון
.זה שמיר החדש, הצעיר. -כן
אחת התמונות שאני אוהב
,שתליתי אותה גם בכנסת
?זה כשהוא אומר: מה אפשר לעשות
.שום דבר לא צריך
.אל תעשו כלום
,מה לעשות? פה יש לנו עם בגין
.תמונה טובה. -כן
.יש לך תמונה שלו גם מהמחתרת
.כן, אבל זה לא שאני צילמתי
.כן-
.זה רפרודוקציה
.ייזרצסקי. -כן
...את זה צילמתי רק מה
רגע, עוד תמונה
.מאוד קלאסית שלו
.שאני מאוד אוהב אותה
.לא
,זה מתאים
.לא צריך לעשות שום דבר
.אני לא יודע כלום
...גאון הוא לא היה אבל
.רונלד רייגן
.גם פה עם רייגן
.בדשא. -כן
.זהו, אז אני עשיתי סדרת ראיונות
,היה אצלך... -מתנחלים
?אני יודע מי זה היום
.לא, זה מגוש קטיף
.יש לנו עוד
.או, זה מעניין
.צ'אושסקו ברומניה. -כן
.פה הוא יושב עם... הוא והלנה. -כן
בארמון. בחוץ היה קר
...ואנשים ישבו
,בכניסה לבית, לארמון
,הייתה מנורה אחת
.ואט 40
.בחדר השני כבר היה יותר
,בחדר השלישי, עוד יותר
.עד שהגעת לחדר הזה
ככה. זו הייתה חוויה לא רגילה
.לראות את זה
.זה אולי מעניין
...אם אתה מדבר על
,בבוקרשט
.בבית הכנסת בבוקרשט
ואני רואה שאני עוזר לך
.קצת עם... -בהחלט, בהחלט
.פנטסטי
.אתה תופס או ש... -כן, כן
,לא, אבל זה בסדר
אני קיבלתי יותר
.ממה שהבטחת לי בזמן הזה
.או.קיי-
,רק אם אתה מרשה
.אני מוכן לסגור
.אתה יכול, כן
...יש בקשה אחת, כל
.'מערכת הבחירות של 88
.כן, כן-
.זה בארץ
...לפי הלבוש של האישה
.כן, לא, זה הכנה כנראה לעימות
.כן, כן-
.כן, כן
,לא סימפטית ביותר
.אבל מאוד קלאסית
.קלאסית של שמיר. -כן